we're on the 14th episode of this series
you think that we would have run out of
ideas by now well if you've been keeping
up you always know there's something new
around the corner with each episode so
if you continue to enjoy this series let
us know with a like alright here you go
sometimes high knocks carry key shrine
pieces that require a bit of work to get
usually sneaking it off them or shooting
it off their necklace
but that's not entirely necessary just
have them do all the hard work and wait
for them to do an attack that brings her
neck down far enough to put the orb in
the slot for you
there's a recently found glitch called
hold prompt storage that's been making
headlines in the breath of the wild
community allowing the strange ability
to hold items normally impossible by
performing complex menu manipulation
similar to memory storage you can hold
the item prompt as you play the game
then picking up a different item and
pause in the game this can allow you to
hold items from the key items menu while
most items don't translate out into the
open world some do such as the
paraglider and the chica slate which are
actually then considered ingredients and
can be cooked into a nice yummy meal
although i would not try to feed this to
gordon ramsay
that's what i got given
fairies appear in the overworld when
cutting grass and when you have fewer
than three fairies in your inventory and
players often pick up a couple extra
fairies at one of the four great fairy
fountains but there are so many more
locations that the fairies can appear
such as these puddles at garuda canyon
the top of the great deku tree below the
bridge in front of the horse god this
random puddle near far on woods the
lover's pond on ebon mountain and this
one random guardian across from the
bottomless swamp
four pieces of wood can keep it updraft
going but did you know that you can keep
an updraft going with active flame
blades if you drop a flame blade
mid-swing it will keep its igniting
effects while on the ground and each one
can substitute for one bundle of wood to
keep the updraft active
there's been a long-running qa team
starting way back in the n64 days called
the mario club located in kyoto they are
a debug team in charge of qa and testing
many famous nintendo titles and they did
work on breath of the wild funny thing
is that we can sort of tell what they
messed around with in the game files
there are multiple actor files listed as
mario club test dungeon and shows all
the tools this debug team had at their
disposal to mess with the physics and
breath of the wild but unfortunately the
actual level itself was not saved one
user recreated this test dungeon as best
they could which shows all the tools the
debug team had at their disposal to mess
with the physics of breath of the wild
these guys are likely very hard at work
for the upcoming sequel
breath of the wild fans already know
that skydiving is arriving in some
fashion in the sequel shown in the 2021
trailer but did you know this is not a
new mechanic at all it was actually
tested during the original development
of breath of the wild old videos still
show test footage of link skydiving over
a mock-up of kyoto but as everyone knows
now this mechanic didn't make it into
the first game it's theorized that
nintendo initially tried some skywars
sword mechanics but then intentionally
saved the idea to implement it fresh
into the next game
as you sneak around the yiga clan's
hideout you can see yiga members carry
torches to look for any possible
invaders well turns out you can straight
up replace those boring old regular
fires with the ancient flame with a bit
of work you can carry the fire from one
of the ancient tech labs put out the
blade masters current fire then light
them up with your own ancient flame
nothing really game breaking but the
fact that this is even possible is
pretty neat
did you know that said on holds a
mysterious weapon most players didn't
take a close look at his hip and
suspected that this was just a silver
sword but it's actually a completely
unique blade that's not listed anywhere
it's an extremely rare occurrence but
some lozalfos when carrying two handed
weapons can put up their arm to block
attacks barehanded this can be guard
broken as well
[Music]
on the main menu screen and in all the
game art for breath of the wild there
are some beautiful shots of link looking
upon the wide land of hyrule while the
ground link is standing or climbing on
is prettied up for promotional purposes
the views he's looking at are real
locations in the game such as this one
climbing the tall cliff looking north
east next to mount grenade and this one
facing northeast right on top of satori
mountain
[Music]
and this one facing northwest from the
top of the dueling peaks
there's an interesting side effect found
through the memory storage glitch that
allows you to save a save file but
without actually having the game started
if this happens the save file will be
blank but say it was saved on january
1st of 1970. this date is actually less
about breath of the wild itself and is
more about how time is recorded
internationally called unix time it's a
system that sets the date based on the
number of values given to it if the
number is zero from this glitch it sets
it to what's called the unix epoch the
beginning of the system started on
january 1st of 1970. there are a few
select places in the game that require
you to shoot down ropes to drop the ramp
for you well on the chances that you get
the angle to just line them both up and
shoot both ropes at the same time
or you know just throw a well-placed
boomerang instead
did you know that the zora used goron
tools
if you look closely at the stone smiths
repairing the zora domain they're all
using a hammer and chisel and these have
the the dongo footprint goron watermark
embedded in them just like every forging
and mining tool the gorons use
there's a glitch found last year called
lionel duplication a fun way to face off
against two lynels at once in the
coliseum but if you're a complete
masochist or just want a taste of age of
calamity in breath of the wild try
knocking down every enemy into the
center of the coliseum all of which are
duplicated as well
once they're all down there enter fight
club to face off against a whopping 20
enemies at once good luck targeting all
of
them
most zelda fans have already noticed the
metal work at the back of hyrule castle
sanctum the triforce with what looks
like music notes surrounding the sides
these notes are a reference to zelda's
lullaby
[Music]
but not only that this whole contraption
is another reference to the gate of time
and skyward sword
at the highland stable there's a horse
mini game which consists of 10 horse
jump obstacles you have to clear and
they give you instructions on which way
to go but there's no hard set rule on
this you can completely do this in the
opposite direction as well
as a matter of fact you can do these
jumps in any order you want although
your time will suffer pretty bad if you
jump them in a random order
there were many storyboards during the
development of breath of the wild but
here's a look at the initial storyboard
drawn up for the introduction of the
great plateau
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
with a little bit of patience you could
trick book goblins into stealing your
force by creating a shock wave to knock
everyone off their mount and stun the
horses at the same time the moment the
horses become unstunned it becomes a
free-for-all for the bokoblins trying to
get back on their mount sometimes
getting on the wrong horse entirely in
the frenzy seeing a gold cobbled archer
riding a lord of the mountain is truly a
terrifying experience
and that's it for this episode it's
coming close to a full year since we
first started so i want to thank
everyone who's enjoyed these videos if
you missed an episode we have a playlist
with all the videos in order for you for
everything else gaming though keep it
here on gamespot
[Music]
you